hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video today is uh
Monday December 26th you know markets
are closed so it's a good day to sort of
uh just sort of recap some things that
are working in the markets and you know
explain a little bit more in depth uh on
on ways to use order flow so today I'll
be talking about the bonds 30
year bonds the ZB Futures trades on the
Board of Trade I'm looking at a five
minute chart and you know bonds is a
great market for trading uh it has nice
movements and you know especially if
you're scalping on a short term you know
a tick size is
31.25 so you know even if you're just
pulling out four or five ticks you know
it's already 150 bucks that you can uh
you know relax on you don't need to be
in and out every day you know with a
bunch of Trades you know as long as you
pick your spots uh carefully you know
you only really need to make one or two
trades a day in the bonds
now what I'll be talking about
specifically is imbalances okay because
you know I'm I hear a lot of chatter
about you know some new tools by uh
people out there with uh imbalances and
I'm going to talk about how I use
imbalances now I'm on a five minute
chart on the bonds you know people
always ask you know because I do a lot
of videos and I'm on you know a one
minute chart oftentimes or a tick based
chart and people I do get messages
saying you know what about you know a
five minute chart in this or that so I'm
showing you on the five minute chart now
when I'm looking at imbalances okay you
know there's a couple things you have to
keep in mind right I like to know where
the high or the low of the day is
um because that's going to affect on you
know if if I'm going to take the
imbalance or not so
again this red line here is the low of
the day right you can see the red line
here and again that is a free indicator
on ninja Trader if you just were to open
up the ninjatrader choices of indicators
you just scroll down in here you just
find current day open high low close
right I've done videos on the importance
of of trading around the low now
when I'm going when the market is going
into a low as you see here right the
market had you know this is
the law of the day we're coming in again
now this is the 23rd of um December you
know the day right before everyone goes
on vacation
and this red line is the low you're
going to you know selling and balances
coming into the low okay well that's
where you expect to see them right you
expect to see them here right as you're
making the new lows it's not something
that I really like to sell into right
because I know there's there's
aggressive trading going into the low
which is what you expect to see when
you're going into low now does that mean
you can't take the trade no of course
you could take the trade but you know
your profit potential you know how much
you can get out of the trade
in my opinion is a bit more limited I
like to look for a reason to be buying
off of a low
um you know with the aggressive trading
coming into the markets now what I have
on here this is my order flows Trader
software I'm looking for stacked
imbalances or multiple imbalances I'm
using a ratio of four to one and I got
one two three selling imbalances coming
into the low that's why there's this red
box around it
when we make a new low I have one two
three selling imbalances okay that's
where you expect them to see but am I
look what I'm looking for when we're
hanging around the low is the aggressive
buying coming in I'm looking for
you know the stack buying imbalances I'm
looking for on the bars with multiple
imbalances and I don't really see
anything coming in here right it's just
aggressive selling going into the low
which is what you expect to see now as
we're sort of going sideways I do see
some aggressive buying but it's kind of
dispersed okay again this is a five
minute chart and you know each bar has
almost got a buying one bind and balance
now is that enough for me to really get
long no I'm really looking for something
a bit more concrete all right I'm
looking for
um you know that burst of buying coming
in almost all at once and on this day
there really wasn't anything there was
one here later but again we had sort of
made our low and are going sideways now
again this is the 23rd which is
you know the day you know for the Friday
before Christmas
um you know at 10 o'clock we got some
aggressive buying coming in here we got
one two three four five buying
imbalances again I'm looking for this to
come in after we made the low this low
was made at 8 20. this is coming in at
10 o'clock it's coming in at 10 o'clock
yeah on Friday after uh going into the
Friday afternoon sort of
um I'm really looking for the move to
happen it doesn't happen it just goes
inside inside then you start to tick up
a little bit and then just inside inside
and you know eventually sort of went
back down towards the low here at at
noon
um but the day before it was much more
clearer right on the 22nd now again you
know if you're trading bonds you're not
going to get
trades left and right that you would get
in the e-minis or or the mes or NQ
because you know bonds move a lot slower
right and for me that's one of the
benefits of the bonds it gives you time
to react okay so here's the bonds right
730 we're coming down making new lows
making new lows eight o'clock eight ten
and then at 8 40 we make a new low here
at uh what is that 128 even right but
this time
as we hit the low right we made the low
at 8 35 on the 840 bar you're seeing the
aggressive buying coming in with one two
three mining balances now these are not
stacked these are spread out throughout
the bar hence that's why we have the box
drawn around it right and then even in
the next bar you still got another three
coming in right with the Box drawn
around the bar you see and you get that
move up right you get that move from
basically 12 all the way up towards uh
the 20 area over here you get a nice
stack binding balance but again if
you're looking only at stacked
imbalances
you don't have a stack binding balance
down here your stack binding balance
comes up here that's why I always say
you know it's important to also pay
attention to the bars that have multiple
imbalances that are just not stacked
neatly on top of each other yes while
it's nice to have them stack neatly on
top of each other
sometimes it that's just not how the
market is shaping up
okay so you can only trade what the
market lets you trade
um so this was on the Thursday the 22nd
uh let's go back another day here
Wednesday I don't think there was
anything
um earlier you know we're going into the
high here you've seen the multiple
binding balances what again that's what
you're expecting to see if I'm at the
high I'm going to start looking for bars
with the multiple selling imbalances
right I don't have anything over here
you do get them coming in over here
stacked and balanced stacked and
balanced but by this time we had already
moved uh well off our high
go back another day right because if I
just show one day with it like people
think oh this is the greatest thing you
know but put it in context with what the
markets are doing on this day you know
we're well within our range the low is
here this is oh is that the 20th uh kind
of a quiet session
um we'll go back previous day
okay so we're at our lows here right
again
no
multiple imbalances In These Bars kind
of quiet you can see I could tell it's
quiet just by looking at you know these
pointed controls are lined up for almost
an hour in here from you know 11 o'clock
to almost 12 o'clock
right all these bars consecutive
imbalances I got multiple selling
balances just right going into the low
stack selling okay that's that's what
I'm expecting now here this was our low
we made this low at 8 10. it starts to
go sideways then the aggressive buying
comes in great that's what I like to see
however you still gotta wait and see how
the next bar is going to shape up is it
going to build off of it meaning are we
going to go higher no we don't what do I
mean by go higher is well I know I have
this bar with the aggressive buying
right we're closing at 29 the high is
30. okay I want to see the next bar
trade 31. I want to see it trade double
O it doesn't it doesn't even get up to
30 it opens at 20 at 30. I'm sorry at 29
and then just you know trades down to 28
and then obviously lower okay so even
though I got my sort of my trigger here
with the order flow I don't have that
follow through because no matter what
how how
greet you on point your analysis is if
there's not that follow through order
flow
don't expect the market to go in that
direction because it's not just oh you
you see something in the order flow or
you have this super great indicator that
says buy or sell if there's no
follow-through the move is just not
going to happen
okay so you know it's not just oh I got
my multiple imbalances I just
immediately got to get long no
wait for it let the market
tell you that yeah you know what this
move is happening it's taking place get
in right and you know people say well
aren't you giving up a tick or two by
getting in a 31 or double O well I'd
rather give up a tick or two on the
trade because I do know it can go higher
much higher
than get into the trade and have a
losing trade
right that that's you know your goal as
a Trader is to manage that risk so let's
just go back um another day okay that
was the then what was that that was the
the 19th so go back to the week before
here we are
um get my chart up here okay so this is
the 16th and again you know the stack
selling imbalance is going into the low
that's what you expect to see can you
trade them of course you can I'm not
saying you shouldn't I just tend to stay
away from them because I do know that
yeah while you know we can go lower like
here we went from 19 down to 08 but it
might just go from 19 down to 16 and
then go sideways and reverse back up now
in this bar you got this stacked buying
and balance now this is kind of a
wide-ranging bar it's kind of a big bar
for the bonds I mean you're talking from
15 all the way up to 28 so 13 tick bar
in the bonds granted it's a five minute
chart but I want to see this Market
again start to move away it doesn't it
only goes one tick the next bar doesn't
go any any higher than the high of this
bar with the Stacked imbalance
next Marlin goes one tick higher than it
sort of comes back in now what was
encouraging is I know I have the Stacked
buying imbalance right and that's going
to be a support area
Market pulls back into that area where
you have that aggressive buying and if
it pulls back into the aggressive buying
in this case it's a stack buying
imbalance what I want to see is if it
can hold because this is a support area
just as the Stack's selling a balance in
here could potentially be a resistance
area I'd be looking for this Market to
potentially you know we hit that low
come back up see if it can hold this
area
you know and then start to sell back
down into new lows it didn't it blew
right through it now we have a stacked
bind imbalance here Market went higher
it's coming back in there and I'm seeing
some you know some buying aggressive
trading going on here this 179
against 37 you know nine against 55
. so there is some slight um you know
aggressive buying taking place
if you want to see it start to trade
away from that area okay
starting to trade away you know 20 21 22
23 finally it makes that move up
okay but you know a stacked imbalance is
a form of support right you guys because
you have aggressive buying coming in at
a certain area I don't say level because
you know level you think of one price
but really when you're dealing with
imbalances especially stacked imbalances
you're looking at an area sort of a zone
right so having it drawn out until
tested is is useful especially when you
see it holding and then start to move
away it starts to move away you could
feel that yeah you know what this
support is holding and you know I can
get long and now some people I know how
they trade stacked imbalances
you know the market leaves a stacked in
Balance here we're trading up here they
just throw a bid in somewhere in that
imbalance right with a stop just on the
other side
right and trades like this work out
nicely trade like here right you have
your stack selling balance between 20
and 22. you either just throwing an
offer at 21 with a stop up here at 23.
fine they lose two ticks here they throw
in a bid at you know 17 or 18. they get
long you know with the stop at 15. again
they're risking two or three ticks and
you know even if you're getting long in
here at 18 or even 19 you know move all
the way up to 29.
let's say talking your our your wrist
reward is you know obviously much better
than one to one
um in this case you're seeing you know
two three even four to one sometimes
so you know that's a way that you could
use stacked imbalances or multiple
imbalances right keep it in context of
the market
right just don't trade them all blindly
uh you know the way I like to look at it
is again you know if you have you're at
the low and you see aggressive buying
coming in that's a good sign to go long
or if you're at a high and you see
aggressive selling coming in it's a good
reason to get short so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video be sure to like And
subscribe like the channels like the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel so whenever I post a new
video you know you'll be alerted to it
so thanks everyone have a great uh rest
of your boxing day your December 26th
holiday and I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye bye